good Adam better hurry up it's like the
guy never listens to me
chapstick okay I'm going to suck you in
the mouth if you don't cut it out with
that crap it's not crap it's farts whoa
TMI
it stands for too much information oh we
weren't even that's no I don't care come
on have a seat
not this one okay a little B G on me uh
I do HR means Human Resources you're at
TAC my name is Eric Rossdale some people
call me cool Eric they called me that
once some young people to some young
someone young person did that I love
people to say that another way I love
people and that one's got a little more
fun to it doesn't it
okay we are here today why are you
pointing in and help out with substance
abuse web just trying to bring everybody
to help out with substance abuse okay
and how do I do that well one way is to
work through this workbook start to
finish we do every single drill in this
thing I sign a piece of paper saying
you've cleaned up your act but more
importantly we have dug out the roots of
your addiction and you're looking at me
like what happened to that guy we called
cool two seconds ago
he's right here how about this instead
how about we fire up some stepbrothers
on the blu-ray we chill out a little bit
how does that sound to you yeah it
sounds awesome okay great before we
start let me do some attendance if
that's okay uh black Anderson uh I think
that's me Oh terrific
Oh cuz of the curly hair like a black
man that's fun anders holmvik yeah yeah
a Norwegian yeah yeah one today oh is
that not only big pardon guy did much of
a whole language oh oh you should oh no
it's a beautiful country and adam demamp
actually Adams running oh I am aiyla
well I hope you like sandwiches out cuz
I got a backpack full of them